so please welcome without further Ado
the one and only Heather Locklear
[Applause]
how sweet are you my little daughter I I
loved being your daughter you don't even
remember oh I remember everything about
it are you kidding oh I have the
sharpest memory with all of that stuff
yeah wow that's crazy absolutely in fact
you know what
it happens to be Friday and you know all
the kids do fun things on social media
and I thought we would just incorporate
it to get into some of our favorite
things about you on a little thing we're
gonna call Flashback Friday
[Applause]
I would love to be a fly on the wall for
some of your extraordinary iconic roles
but I can't not kick it off with a fire
starter I mean Hello fantastic
um
you are just amazing from head to toe
from then till now and then continued
but you know I was only 21 at the time
and I'm like I couldn't believe I was
playing a mother of a little guy I'm
like I have no idea I have no younger
siblings I don't even know how what I'm
doing and um you helped like you were
just charming and adorable oh I'm so
glad good I we're a great girl
that makes me so happy what's the real
lives we live in I know it's true the
entertainment
work but then also like I literally
every Monday every Wednesday night had
parties with my friends we had watching
parties of Melrose Place Amanda Woodward
d d advertising can you TNT I'm a very
important
can you please give me like
a first thing that comes to your mind or
a fly on the wall experience from
Melrose Place okay first of all I had
those parties because I wasn't on for
the first 18 episodes so I was like look
at this great show that then people go
you should be on it I'm like I'm too old
to be on it and you know everyone was in
their 20s and I was almost 30. and um
but a FL you know fly on the wall it was
always a lot of work and
um but I thought the kind of the coolest
part is I was married and I got to bed
hop with all these handsome actors and
make out and I was like what a great job
I have so you know you can't do it with
other people if you're married but if
it's your work thank you
I know it's the strangest relationship
conversation you know some people are
cool with it and some people are really
not cool with that and it's a very
surreal thing it is you know Grant show
um was dating someone on the show for a
while and I think he wanted to honor her
and we had a bed scene and you know he
had no shirt on and I don't know what I
had on and under the covers he had
full-on jeans and work boots yeah I'm
like
um so it was just really I thought it
was really sweet of him to make you know
the girl feel good uh okay oh my God I
don't think that the world would be the
same without the show Dynasty
oh yeah
yeah great people
I mean that like on a pop culture level
I mean that on an ensemble successful
show level
um what was it like to be in Dynasty
first of all it was incredibly gorgeous
the set looked like a real home they had
at that time they had real like they had
huge floral arrangements everywhere and
they were real
and I mean I'm like that's a lot of
money it's like five grand or something
I think for those big things I mean it
is gorgeous said slake Carrington Lake
Carrington yes and who who is now played
by Grant show no yes in the new Dynasty
isn't that crazy that is crazy okay TJ
hooker
okay well I'll tell you a little about
um when I first got on I had they have
the uniform for me and they go we need
to give her a padded bra and it was
really padded and so I'm like okay I'll
put that on and then one you know a
couple weeks later they go I see
something in my dressing room and it's a
like underwear with a butt in it and I'm
like you are not gonna make me wear my
butt's too flat my boobs are too flat
and so I go I am not wearing these butt
things and I'm not wearing this bra look
and then I became Stacey Sheridan
for you
I love it I'm I'm actually gonna show a
picture and a little bit of what your
body exactly was and it is
it literally you know what just forget
it bring it up right now because it's
been living rent free in my mind oh
right
that's great I mean
I you don't alter Perfection that's all
I've oh okay you can tell those
customers and those people like that I
mean you you're so stunning you're so
funny I think I still have that top
um I but I do and I have like a rainbow
one uh and then I'm the makeup though
that was the 80s it was truly
and a lot of makeup a lot of makeup oh I
love it
[Music]